Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This video is not about a paper, but the about
the video series itself.
I don't do this often, but for the sake of
transparency, I wanted to make sure to tell
you about this.
We have recently hit 175.000 subscribers on
the channel!
I find this number almost unfathomable.
And please know that this became a possibility
only because of you, so I would like to let
you know how grateful I am for your support
here on YouTube and Patreon.
As most of you know, I still work as a full-time
researcher at the Technical University of
Vienna and I get the question "why not go
full time on Two Minute Papers?"
from you Fellow Scholars increasingly often.
The answer is that over time, I would love
to, but our current financial situation does
not allow it.
Let me explain that.
First, I tried the run the channel solely
on YouTube ads, which led to a rude awakening
- most people (myself included) are very surprised
when they hear that the rates had become so
low that around the first one million viewer
mark, the series earned less than a dollar
a day.
Then, we introduced Patreon, and with your
support, now we are able to buy proper equipment
to make better videos for you.
I can, without hesitation, say that you are
the reason this channel can exist.
Everything is better this way: now we have
two independent revenue sources (Patreon being
the most important), however, whenever YouTube
or Patreon monetization issues arise, you
see many other channels disappearing into
the ether.
I am terrified of this and I want to do everything
I possibly can to make sure that this does
not happen to us and we can keep running this
series for a long-long time.
However, if anything happens to any of these
revenue streams, simply put, we are toast.
Even though it would be a dream come true,
because of this, it would be irresponsible
to go full time on the papers.
To remedy this, we have been thinking about
introducing a third revenue stream with sponsorships
for a small amount of videos each month.
The majority, 75% of the videos would remain
Patreon supported, and the remaining 25% would
be sponsored, just enough to enable me and
my wife to do this full time in the future.
There would be no other changes to the videos,
Patreon supporters get all of them in early
access, and as before, I choose the papers
too.
With this, if something happens to any one
of the revenue streams, we would be able to
keep the series afloat without any delays.
I would also have more time to every now and
then, fly out and inform key political decision
makers on the state of AI so they can make
better decisions for us.
Everything else would remain the same, the
videos would arrive more often in time, and
the dream could perhaps come true.
I think transparency is of utmost importance
and wanted to make sure to inform you before
any change happens.
I hope you are okay with this.
And, if you are a company and you are interested
in sponsoring the series, let's talk.
As always thanks for watching and for your
generous support, and I'll see you next time!